[Musique]
11 septembre 2020 j'ai vécu un véritable
bouleversement
ok ce n'était pas l'effondrement des
twin towers
mais c'était tout comme pour moi petit
je voulais être médecin
comme mes parents mais à force d'avoir
entendu rabâcher 116 j'en aurais pour 15
ans d'études que je ne choisirai pas
forcément librement ma spécialité ni mon
lieu d'habitation
je me suis finalement orienté vers le
métier de consultant
après avoir travaillé sur deux plans
sociaux
1 en france et un en suède à 30 ans j'ai
décidé et j'ai eu envie d'apporter de la
valeur aux autres plutôt que d'en
détruire c'est comme ça que je me suis
retrouvé devant une couche d'orientation
qui après trois séances me propose de
devenir directeur d'ehpad
de quoi lui a répondu vous imaginez vous
de passer d'un métier de consultant
la tranquille derrière son ordinateur à
devoir vous occupez de personnes âgées
de plus en plus dépendante et après tout
pourquoi pas c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours eu un profond respect pour les
personnes âgées et je voulais me rendre
utile en apportant une meilleure qualité
de vie et trouver ainsi un métier
éthique porteur de sens bourg au bout de
quelques mois
me voilà directeurs de maisons de
retraite médicalisées et au bout de six
ans je suis toujours là toujours habité
par le profond désir de faire évoluer
les choses auprès de ces personnes
vulnérables et de toutes mes équipes qui
les accompagnent et cela malgré la crise
sanitaire qui a considérablement
bouleversé la donne avant de vous en
dire plus je voudrais juste vous
partager quelques chiffres je suis
directeur d'une résidence dans laquelle
nous accueillons 103 résidents derrière
ce chiffre nous avons 103 personnes et
ses 103 femmes
qui ont chacun chacune leurs
préoccupations et leurs histoires de vie
être directeur c'est garantir avant tout
une qualité la gestion la qualité des
soins de la restauration de l'hôtellerie
des ressources humaines du développement
commercial tout en étant pénalement
responsable sacrée responsabilité dont
j'ai pleinement pris conscience
le 11 septembre 2020 car oui le 11
septembre 2020 à 21h30 je reçois un coup
de fil de notre laboratoire qui
m'annonce que nous avons notre premier
résident covit positif waouh gros coup
de massue pour moi un vrai
bouleversement en urgence j'organise le
dépistage massif de tous les salariés de
tous les résidents d'ems matin 8 heures
du matin
nous organisons une réunion de crise
avec tous les toutes les équipes afin de
mettre en place les protocoles covit sur
le terrain un seul mot d'ordre c'est de
rassurer les salariés
nous avons les équipements nécessaires
pour assurer votre sécurité et nous
allons créer une zone qu'ovide afin de
ne pas propager le virus dans toute la
résidence
on ferme établissements ont confiné
résidents en chambre plus aucune visite
plus aucun intervenant même magali la
coiffeuse ne peut plus intervenir c'est
si soudain que certains salariés panique
les résidentes comprennent plus et les
familles sont terrorisés résultat des
courses dimanche 13 septembre
nous avons six résidents et quatre
salariés positif malheureusement un des
résidents positif se trouve dans notre
unité protégée secteur dans lequel nous
accueillons 13 résidents ayant des
troubles neurocognitifs maladie
d'alzheimer ou maladies parente
apparentés qui déambulent jour et nuit
la pression monte j'appelle notre
médecin hygiéniste de l'hôpital
d'aix-en-provence qui nous accompagne
depuis le début afin qu'elle vienne
rapidement sur le site entre temps
j'envoie un courrier aux familles afin
de les avertir de cette malheureuse
nouvelle
désormais ceux qui nous hante et ceux
qui nous dirigent
ce sont les résultats bcr tous les
matins tous les jours ce sont les mêmes
questions qui reviennent
combien avons-nous de nouveaux résidents
positif combien avons-nous de nouveaux
salariés positif et surtout y at-il eu
des décès au bout de six semaines
si longues semaines de crise nous avions
six résidents des cds sur 22 contaminer
tout au long de ces six semaines
nous avons été confrontés à des choix
difficiles ce qui engage notre éthique
mon éthique
doit-on laisser nos treize résidents
déambuler librement dans cet espace dans
cette unité protégée au risque qui se
contaminent entre eux une autre question
est ce que nous prenons le risque
également de laisser enfermer ses
personnages et de 90 ans seuls dans leur
chambre sans aucun lien social hélas
l'agencé régionale de santé
la rs tout autant démunie knu ne peut
répondre et nous donner des solutions
nous devons trancher et nous faisons le
choix d'autoriser des familles à venir
rendre visite à leurs proches pour des
raisons médicales ou pour des fins de
vie pour les personnes désorientées
nous les laissons librement déambuler
dans ces secteurs protégés
les médicaments thé et les contentieux
né serait complètement contraire à notre
éthique en tant que directeur je me suis
souvent sentie seule face à mes
responsabilités et ses décisions qui
potentiellement pouvait être lourde de
conséquences ce qui m'a conduit ce qui
nous a conduits de faire ce choix avec
le maximum de discernement avec le
maximum de bon sens et d'être le plus
juste pour toutes ces personnes
vulnérables
mais cette période n'a pas été que
difficile elle nous a permis de belles
découvertes en particulier cette
incroyable capacité du collectif à
s'organiser spontanément pour répondre à
cette crise je me souviendrai toujours
de ce samedi matin lorsque je conduisais
seule dans ma voiture en direction de la
résidence et je vous avoue j'avais une
certaine appréhension je ne voulais pas
imposer les choses aux salariés et
surtout faire face à une démobilisation
face à cette crise alors j'avais une
seule idée en tête c'était de nous
souder
j'ai commencé ma réunion en leur disant
j'ai besoin de vous nous avons besoin de
vous et nous devons être tous solidaires
cette réunion fut extraordinaire c'était
une explosion de bonnes idées de prise
d'initiative d' écoute mutuelle
j'ai senti chaque salarié motivé investi
par la situation et par le sort des
résidents
j'ai vu émerger des ressources
insoupçonnées
en termes de prise d'autonomie et de
capacité à s'adapter alors que les
responsables étaient en train de
repenser de contrôler et vérifier la
mise en place des protocoles sur le
terrain les salariés étaient déjà en
train de repenser eux mêmes
leurs tâches journalières en les
adaptant à la situation
certains salariés se sont même proposé
de travailler dans la zone qu'ovide au
risque de ceux d'être contaminé d'autres
même sont venus me proposer de réduire
leur nombre de jour hebdomadaire de
repos afin de ne pas laisser trop
longtemps
seuls les résidents contaminés nous
avons vécu une véritable expérience
d'intelligence collective de ce fameux
un plus un égale 2 et call 3 c'est reese
a été une opportunité d'entre aide aussi
spectaculaires qu'inattendus
moi même j'ai été énormément touchée
j'ai été émerveillé et fier de mes
équipes et de toute la coopération de
nous avons fait preuve
et puis un jour sans aucune explication
tu retrouves les travers d'avant
fini les initiatives les salles
riez sont revenus à une organisation
basique linéaire fondée sur des fiches
de poste des listes de tâches et pour
moi c'était une grosse déception
j'ai réentendu des phrases toutes faites
comme il pas dû le faire s'est pas
inscrit sur ma fiche de tâches
c'est à partir de ce moment là où je me
suis interrogé sur mon mode de
management
généralement dans une égalisation bien
définis dans un souci d'efficacité on
donne peu de responsabilité de salariés
et c'est là une des origines majeur de
la démotivation des gens c'est vrai
chaque jour pour chaque salarié ou leur
demande de cocher des cases pour
justifier leur travail moi même en tant
que directeur je dois remplir des
tableaux de bord pour justifier mon
travail on peut se poser
le sens de ces tâches alors maintenant
je sais je sais que en dehors de tous
ces tableaux de bord mon rôle de manager
et de créer et de faire du lien entre
les activités chaque salarié et leur
impact sur le bien-être des personnes
qu'on accueille et je le fais en posant
cette question si simple du pourquoi
pourquoi fais-tu ce métier pourquoi es
tu aides soignantes
pourquoi es tu un fermier je m'attache à
donner à chaque
marié une place dans notre organisation
et de les aider à prendre conscience de
la valeur de leur travail
notre mission au quotidien et
d'accompagner chaque résident chaque
famille chaque homme chaque femme qui
nous fait confiance
alors oui avec cette question si simple
mais si essentiel du pourquoi en deux
mots dans quel but
et pour faire quoi ça nous a permis de
nous réveiller de remettre au centre
notre sens de l'engagement notre
essentiel et vous cette question si
simple posez là vous en vous disant
pourquoi vous travaillez
[Musique]